beide sind rheinländer sie kennen sich
von ihrer gemeinsamen aber den nrw gut
und sie schätzen sich das ist kein
geheimnis mit fdp chef christian lindner
möchte ich jetzt über den neuen cdu
vorsitzenden armin laschet sehr gerne
sprechen ich grüße sie herr lindner
sie hatten ja wir hatten ja inzwischen
bestimmt die möglichkeit armin laschet
persönlich oder telefonisch zu
gratulieren
haben sie ihm noch etwas mit auf den weg
gegeben tipps wünsche erwartungen
ihrerseits nein armin laschet braucht
keine ratschläge von anderen der hat in
seiner karriere gezeigt dass er eine
führungspersönlichkeit der union ist
ich habe ihm erfolg gewünscht und habe
eben auch nochmal für die fairness
gedankt
auch in diesem parteiinternen wahlkampf
ist ja nicht der versuchung erlegen
die gute regierungsarbeit mit der fdp in
nordrhein-westfalen zu verschweigen
sondern er war der kandidat der sogar
noch offensiver als friedrich merz und
im gegensatz zu norbert röttgen ja aktiv
dafür geworben hat und das zeigt da ist
ein belastbares vertrauensverhältnis das
weckt natürlich deine hoffnung auch bei
ihnen wie fest drücken sie denn jetzt
die daumen dass armin laschet auch
kanzlerkandidat der union wird und nicht
etwa markus söder der ja doch viel
deutlicher zu den grünen die nähe sucht
als zu ihrer partei im gegensatz
versteht ja da haben wir haben wir keine
präferenz das ist allein eine frage der
cdu ich glaube sogar dass in wahrheit
für die fdp es ein vorteil sein könnte
es gebe einen markus söder der offensiv
um die grünen wirbt denn schwarz grün
ist beileibe nicht das koalitionsmodell
dass die bürgerliche mitte in unserem
land in ihrer breite will das heißt ein
kurs wie söder oder röttgen ihnen
forciert haben der würde auch in einer
wahlauseinandersetzung für uns
möglichkeiten bieten war menschen dann
doch eine stimme der marktwirtschaft
eine
stimme auch der individuellen freiheiten
der verhältnismäßigkeit wünschen würden
ich gehe allerdings davon aus dass armin
laschet der favorit ist für die
kanzlerkandidatur und das hängt mit
einem einzigen grund zusammen die cdu
ist sehr erfolgsorientiert und armin
laschet ist eben ein sehr guter
wahlkämpfer
er hat es vermocht ja in nordrhein
westfalen mit der fdp gemeinsam eine
schwarz gelbe regierung zu bilden und
schwarz gelb in nordrhein westfalen zu
regieren das ist so als wenn die csu in
bayern eine absolute mehrheit hätte
dann lassen sie uns noch mal weiter über
die von ihnen erhoffte zusammenarbeit im
bund sprechen was wäre denn mit einer
lasche cdu in ihren augen möglich was
mit einer merkel cdu damals bei den
jamaika verhandlungen für sie unmöglich
war
armin laschet steht für eine faire
zusammenarbeit ist ja interessant jetzt
diesen vergleich zu machen
2017 habe ich gemeinsam mit armin
laschet in düsseldorf für das land
nordrhein westfalen eine schwarz gelbe
zusammenarbeit verabredet innerhalb von
vier wochen stand die gesamte
regierungspolitik im bund haben wir vier
wochen unter führung von frau merkel
sondiert und nach einem monat
sondierungen war nur klar wo sich die
partner unterscheiden uns konkret zu
machen
in der jamaika konstellation in berlin
war es nicht möglich ein digital
ministerium zu verabreden dass die ganz
offensichtlich durch die pandemie noch
deutlicher gewordenen defizite zb in der
öffentlichen verwaltung hinsichtlich der
digitalisierung abstellt in nordrhein
westfalen gibt es an digitalisierungs
ministerium im bund war es nicht möglich
eine politik der marktwirtschaftlichen
erneuerung zu verabreden mit der
entlastung von bürokratie mit entlastung
bei den steuern
genau das ist in düsseldorf möglich
gewesen wir haben jetzt schon das dritte
sogenannte entfesselung paket
beschlossen ganz konkret spürbar werden
dort die bürokratischen lasten reduziert
nordrhein westfalen hat die menschen
freundlichste bleibe regelung für
menschen die aus dem ausland zu uns
kommen
zugleich werden dort mehr aber sich
illegal bei uns aufhalten
menschen abgeschoben als überall sonst
im bundesgebiet mit frau merkel im bund
war es nicht möglich ein rationales
modernes einwanderungsgesetz zu
verabreden vertrauen sie mir ich könnte
diese liste weiter fortsetzen wird
sie hat einen eine pointe man kann frau
merkel gar nicht vorwerfen dass die
dinge anders nicht machen wollte wenn
man nämlich wie sie so viele jahre im
amt ist will man kann den neuen kapitel
aufschlagen und das ist der unterschied
zum bund jetzt beim nächsten mal nach
dieser bundestagswahl wird es in jedem
fall söder laschet eine persönlichkeit
sein die neue eigene akzente im bund
setzen kann und das bietet für alle
beteiligten eben chancen auch eigene
punkte die einem wichtig sind
unterzubringen
ok wunschpartner seien die liberalen das
hat armin laschet am samstag im zdf noch
einmal wiederholt aber er könne nicht
auch noch die probleme der fdp lösen
wie wollen sie denn die probleme ihrer
partei bis zur bundestagswahl lösen also
schwarz gelb allein ist ja nicht
wirklich realistisch von welchem problem
sprechen wir haben sie keine probleme
die umfragewerte zwischen fünf und
sieben prozent ist das für sie in
ordnung von sie das bis zur
bundestagswahl
so halten naja ich empfehle einen blick
mal zurück in den vergleich vor der
bundestagswahl 2017 sind wir auf einem
deutlich niedrigeren niveau in den
umfragen in das wahljahr gestartet ich
glaube dass er sogar in einzelnen
umfragen sogar noch im mai juni 2017 bei
5 prozent standen jetzt stehen wir
ausweislich der umfragen etwa der ard
bei nur deutlichen 7
trotz der dominanz der exekutive in der
pandemie
obwohl die themen wo wir gute beiträge
leisten können also die befreiung
unseres staates aus dem schuldensumpf
die wirtschaftliche erholung sicherung
von arbeitsplätzen technologische
innovationen die themen kommen überhaupt
erst mal auf die agenda also verglichen
mit dem jahr 2017 starten die mit einer
besseren ausgangslage in das wahljahr
2021 und deshalb ist natürlich noch
nichts gewonnen nichts ist
ein selbstläufer aber wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir nach einem
engagierten wahlkampf in diesem jahr
erneut mit einem zweistelligen ergebnis
in den bundestag einziehen können so wie
wir das 2017 ja auch getan haben also
die probleme in der fdp scheint nicht
sehr groß zu sein sagt christian lindner
der parteichef vielen dank für das
gespräch
ich danke ihnen das nicht